you're like I feel like you are uh kind
of an anomaly in a crew like Griselda
yeah right like we think of gun we think
of uh Conway Benny it's high level Coke
rap it's
you know yeah it's we know what it is
right and then there's Armani Caesar
who's like you know one of those pretty
girls in hip-hop and obviously you could
wrap your ass off but you're also very
much like a different
um you're bringing something different
to the crew yeah um when did you
initially link up with gun and like how
did you guys eventually get on each
other's radar to where you ended up
working with Griselda officially so I
met gun back and when I was still living
in Buffalo I was like a teenager and
um we met through DJ Shea that's how I
met all the guys through DJ Shay where I
was in a group all together called buff
City and then once I left for school and
then everybody kind of disbanded you
know did their own thing I was in buff
City it was me Conway Benny
um
Hyde was in it rick hide was it shout
out to my guy Rick Hyde yes I just
realized that and like it was like uh
food Crews
um who else is in love City this is
prior to you going to college so this is
like how old are you like 18 17 like 17
just turned 17. wow okay yeah so then I
just kind of you know they met me I went
in there for some studio time
um and they had another rap trick in
here at the time and Benny was like
helping her write a verse or whatever
because she was gonna be like the first
lady of the city at the time gotcha so
when it was like they were going over
the verse and they kept playing
instrumental I wrote my own verse and
then somebody heard me rapping it and
then Benny you know came over heard me
tap Shay like yo like she fired instead
of third long story short I ended up in
a group just like that wow so that was
kind of like the first time you had like
really linked up with the guys over
there in general yeah yeah so you go to
school you said North Carolina Central
HBCU yeah uh what were you going to
school for so I was a um I was a few
things
but I ended up a marketing major
business administration with a
concentration of marketing but like all
of my prereqs were like you know pretty
much the same and like Staples that you
needed for every class except for the
hip-hop and context class there was a
hip-hop and contacts class was that the
one the ninth Wonder was teaching yeah I
just saw him repost that and say you
never know who's in the classroom yes so
it was crazy like because I even gave
him the mixtape that I had back in the
day it was called bath and body work oh
wow that's great
you know he was he was showing love like
you know he was still he was just real
cool it was a bunch of people in the
class but essentially like it really
kind of got me into a journey of like
going and doing my research on the
Roxanne shantae's on the NC lights like
the people that weren't like mainstream
like the Kims and Foxy's right so you
think like taking that class kind of
helped you like sharpen your hip-hop
Head Metal if you will for sure I mean
we would just be walking in a class and
like he would be playing a sample and
then he had played a song that sampled
it like you know that kind of thing like
so that got me in my sample bag that got
me like digging for Beats and like even
inspiring me to just go back and listen
to old school music so were you like uh
motivated to go check out little brother
at all his group yeah I love little
brothers little brothers one of my
favorite rap groups ever yeah they was
fired well they still are fine they put
a good album out a couple years ago a
few years ago before the pandemic shout
out Fontaine big poop yes I gotta check
that out yeah
um so you go to school
you get the mark you got a degree no you
didn't finish no I didn't finish once I
was told like you know I think this was
like my junior year and I was trying to
figure out like what I wanted to do and
I was just really going to school just
to appease my mother and my advisor was
like look like I see how you go like in
our marketing class and you could
literally sell I swear eskimos so like
if you can Market yourself you could
really much pretty much do anything and
I guess he was trying to motivate me but
it motivated me to like leave like say
[ __ ] this I'm going to go yeah and you
got now I see why you have you're so
success you got a damn Armani's closet
yeah
is this an online store or actual place
that people can visit it's an online
store
um I'm working on making it like a brick
and mortar but I want it to be like an
experience that's